[Music]
okay you have a time jump confirmed the
episode nine how do you think that
influences where Ray is at because she
was kind of learning the ways in in the
last Jedi where's she at now in terms of
confidence the confidence level is high
year I would say but also there's a lot
to learn in Star Wars world
so even the time jump you could never
sort of fit in that anyone needs to do
into that time so there is growth and
there is also room for growth hmm
now people have a lot of questions about
the relationships and there's a moment
at the end of the last Jedi or Poe and
Rey kind of mean he's like I know and
I'm like I think I'm into this do you
think there's a place for Rey to have a
love interest I guess the thing for me
that was always really exciting is I'd
never felt like it was any like
specified sort of love that we were
betraying mm-hmm so the relationship
between FINRA and Poe and this one I
thought just felt amazing because it's
like it's friendship but it's family and
it's I don't know it's just a lovely
sort of thing and I also think that's
nice like in a film way to not
necessarily have like an overt this is
friendship this is love it's just or a
beautiful
I don't know collection of people I'm
excited to see Ray's relationship with
Rose Tico because we saw that picture of
Ben together so nice you out with Carly
awesome thanks so much
[Music]